AND INGENUOUS AND SHOCKED.
AND WE ARE TOO.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON, MISS
MAYOR.
I APPRECIATE IT.
LOOKING AT TO LIVE OF THE SCHOOL
IN PARKLAND, FLORIDA, MARJORY
STONEMAN DOUGLAS.
AND THAT IS THE FBI AT WORK.
STILL A CRIME SCENE, OF COURSE.
AND WE JUST HAD CONFIRMATION IF
YOU ARE JUST TUNING IN THAT
APPARENTLY THE BODIES REMAIN
INSIDE THE SCHOOL, UNFORTUNATELY
INSIDE THE SCHOOL, UNFORTUNATEL
UNFORTUNATELY.
GEORGE IS A STUDENT AT MARJORY
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL,
JOINING US BY PHONE.
SO YOU KNEW NIKOLAS CRUZ?
>> YES, I HAD MET HIM.
>> Tucker: WHAT WAS YOUR
IMPRESSION OF HIM?
>> HE WAS ALWAYS A TROUBLEMAKER.
HE WAS ALWAYS THE CLASS CLOWN,
AND ALWAYS TRIED TO MAKE PEOPLE
LAUGH IN THE CLASSROOM AND WOULD
ALWAYS DO BAD THINGS.
>> Tucker: WHAT KIND OF BAD
THINGS?
>> HE WOULD JUST MAKE COMMENTS
TO THE TEACHER AND MESS AROUND,
BASED ON RANDOM THINGS.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU GIVE US AN
EXAMPLE?
>> I REMEMBER EIGHTH GRADE ONE
TIME WHEN THE TEACHER -- HE WENT
ON THE TEACHERS COMPUTER AND
STARTED LOOKING UP THINGS AND
THEN WHEN THE TEACHER WALKED
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM HE JUST
GOT AWAY FROM THE LAPTOP.
>> Tucker: HE WAS EXPELLED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL WE HAVE BEEN
TOLD, DO YOU KNOW WHY HE WAS
EXPELLED?
>> NO, I DO NOT HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT.
>> Tucker: WITHOUT VIOLATING
THE PRIVACY OF ANYONE, BUT WHAT
WAS HIS FAMILY SITUATION LIKE?
>> I REALLY DID NOT KNOW.
AFTER EIGHTH GRADE, WE WENT OUR
SEPARATE WAYS.
I HAD NOT REALLY TALKED TO HIM
SINCE.
>> Tucker: WHEN HE SAW HIS
NAME THIS AFTERNOON IN
CONNECTION WITH THIS MASS
SHOOTING, WHAT WAS YOUR FIRST
RESPONSE?
>> HONESTLY, I DID NOT REALLY
KNOW HOW TO REACT.
I KNEW THAT HE WAS BAD, BUT I
DID NOT KNOW THAT HE WAS THIS
BAD.
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS LIKE
NOBODY DID.
BUT YOU WERE NOT TOTALLY SHOCKED
THEN?
>> I MEAN, I WAS SHOCKED.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT I WAS
SHOCKED.